sometimes people say to me pastor Jeff
how do you know there's a god and I say
it's simple math God either exists or he
doesn't so let's be cynical
worst case scenario there's a 50/50
chance and I like those odds that's
wrong
Chile put your hand down sorry please
continue it's okay Mary it's Sheldon
right yes sir well Sheldon why don't you
come on up here and tell me how I'm
wrong
no okay let's give them a hand everybody
[Applause]
Shelly's gonna need him alive so you
were saying you've confused
possibilities with probabilities
according to your analogy when I go home
I might find a million dollars on my bed
or I might not
and what universe is that 5050 so what
do you think the odds are that God
exists
I think there's zero I believe in
science so you don't think science and
religion can go hand in hand sciences
backs religion is faith
I prefer facts I understand that here's
a cool fact for you
a lot of famous scientists believed in
God Isaac Newton Albert Einstein even
Charles Darwin so Darwin's right about
God and wrong about evolution now you're
getting it let's give it up for Sheldon
everybody what a good sport but I wasn't
a good sport at that moment I vowed to
come back the following Sunday and
destroy pastor Jeff
I thought I'd talk this morning about
how it all began
now everybody knows on the first day of
creation God said let there be light and
there was light
and when God saw that light he knew it
was good oh here we go
yes Sheldon you said he didn't create
the Sun until day four yeah so how could
there be light the first three days God
is light so God's a photon God's what
made photons possible and what day did
he do that
I would think day one I grabbed my chest
until over maybe we can get out of here
that's a terrible thing a Saturday
because the first day had just begun so
before the Big Bang there was no Big
Bang there was only the word was the
word kaboom okay do it okay we gotta go